Alright bleeders.
it’s time to answer the age old question.
do we really need our periods every month?!
Hey everyone, Julia here for DNews
Periods.
Messy, uncomfortable, inconvenient, and expensive.
Seriously expensive.
Some estimates say a woman will spend over
18,000 bucks over the course of her life on
products likes pads and tampons.
I’ve about had it.
I’m ready to never have one again.
But is that possible?
Would it do any harm?
Every month your body prepares for one of
life’s greatest miracles.
The lining of your uterus thickens in response
to hormones like estrogen and progesterone.
It grows into layers and becomes filled with
blood vessels in preparation of egg implantation.
if the egg becomes fertilized and implants
itself in that lining, we call it pregnancy.
And in turn your body punishes you for not
making pregnancy happen.
By shedding the lining, give you lots of cramps
and just messiness.
But along came a little pink pill and changed
everything.
I mean birth control has revolutionized so
much in our society.
From the little pink pill to to the little
copper coil, birth control gave women and
those with a uterus control over their own
bodies.
So you know what, I say screw it, who needs
a period anyways?
Turns out, no one.
Not really.
You don’t really need your period.
So you ready to stop your period?
How?
Just a little pink pill every morning.
Most birth control contains synthetic versions
of the hormones progesterone and estrogen.
These hormones prevent pregnancy in a few
ways.
Some types prevent ovulation by basically
tricking your body into thinking it’s already
released an egg.
This way an egg doesn’t get released.
And the progestin actually prevents the build
up of the lining of your uterus and might
also make the vaginal mucus thicker, making
it more difficult for a sperm to get where
it’s trying to go.
While some pills you take every day for like
21 days and then take a placebo for a week
to menstruate, other types stop menstruation
completely.
And this is completely fine, according to
a 2006 study published in the journal Contraception.
The following year a pill that stops menstruation
completely was approved by the FDA.
The only downside, some people might experience
some breakthrough bleeding or spotting throughout
the month.
And many, many people were really interested.
One survey by the University of Pennsylvania
School of Medicine found that more than two
thirds of women were interested in stopping
their periods.
And even more promising, 97% of physicians
said suppressing menstruation is “medically
safe and acceptable”.
But I should caution that yes, there are some
risks with oral contraceptives,—an increased
risk of blood clots, heart attacks, and stroke.
But on the other hand it can lower the risk
of ovarian and endometrial cancers
I know that sounds so.. strange.
You might think that we need periods to remove
“toxins” or something.
That’s an old belief, one of many that tries
to paint periods as disgusting and dirty.
Like this one physician in 1920 claimed he
found that women release 'menotoxins' during
their period that would actually wilt flowers
if they touched them.
Not kidding.
And there’s nothing true about that to say
the least, but a lot of people still believe
something close to that.
So is having a period every month natural?
Well weirdly some people think we actually
are having MORE periods than we’re supposed
to.
In societies that don’t use birth control,
they tend to have more children.
A lot more.
So women spend much of their reproductive
years pregnant or breastfeeding, meaning they
menstruate less.
Anthropologist Beverly Strassmann of the University
of Michigan, says women in these societies
typically have 100 periods over the course
of their life.
While women in societies that use birth control
have, like 3 to 5 times as many.
That’s just not fair.
And yeah okay, having a period every month
is a kind of nice reminder from mother nature
that HEY YOU AREN’T PREGNANT.
But there’s other ways to know you’re
not pregnant.
And hormonal birth control is reversible.
According to the European Active Surveillance
Study on Oral Contraceptives most women had
no problems getting pregnant after they stopped
taking the pill.
So basically, period havers of the world,
REJOICE!
If the lining of your uterus doesn’t thicken
thanks to oral contraception, you really don’t
need a period.
Alright ladies, so have you ever experienced
those moments where you and your roommates
all are on your period at the same time!?
ICE CREAM AND GREY’S ANATOMY PARTY!
No but seriously, is that even possible?
Amy has the answer in this episode right here.